I'm home.
You won't believe this.
I got fired again.
Terrible, right?
Terrible...
What did you do?
How did you clean before?
The maid did that kind of stuff for me.
Is it true?
Wow, it's a mansion!
-The neighbors' houses all look like this.
-Are you
a rich kid?
No! Not at all!
How much of an allowance did you get?
Allowance?
-I use this.
-That?
A black card?
That's a no-limit credit card!
Yeah. That's it.
I've never seen one before.
But I can't use it.
They'll find out where I am.
Oh, I see.
You ran away from home, right?
Anyway, let's clean up this room.
Let's do it!
We finally have room to sleep.
Thanks.
You know,
if I go straight to sleep when
I'm having a bad day, I get nightmares.
-I know what you mean.
-When that happens,
I think about things I like
before going to sleep.
Let's both tell each other what we like.
-Okay.
-Then I'll start.
Mars-yaki.
-What's that?
-It's a specialty of Alba City.
It's octopus, fried like an alien.
Gross! I want to try it!
Okay. Next.
Something I like?
Assam tapioca milk tea!
That's so girly!
Really?
Timberland boots.
Nice! I've never worn them before.
I always wear them.
The name of my guitar.
Hummingbird!
-That's a cute name!
-Right?
The smell of the river
when I skate along the bank.
-Smell?
-Yeah.
Smell...
The smell of a paperback book.
-Paper?
-Yeah. And...
Cyndi's songs.
I prefer Crystal.
Oh, me, too!
-I like Crystal, too!
-No way! Which song?
Which song was it?
"Unbreakable"!
That's a great song!
But I like "Everything" more!
That's not fair!
-What? Why?
-That's not fair!